>> Laura: FRENCH
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON SPENT
THREE DAYS WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP
LAST WEEK WHILE GERMAN
CHANCELLOR ANGELA MERKEL SPENT
ONLY THREE HOURS.
LET'S GET INSIGHT INTO WHAT IS
REALLY GOING ON AND WELCOME THE
NEWLY CONFIRMED TO U.S.
AMBASSADOR TO GERMANY, I NEVER
THOUGHT I WOULD SAY THAT, RIC
GRENELL FROM LOS ANGELES.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
I WANT A STEIN OF BEER TO TOAST
YOU BUT I GUESS I CAN'T DO THAT
ON NATIONAL TV.
HOW ARE YOU DOING?
ARE YOU FEELING GOOD?
>> AND FEELING GREAT.
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART IS,
TODAY, I AM FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS CANCER FREE.
>> Laura: I SAW THAT TO EACH.
YOU AND I ARE STRIVERS,
CANCEROUS DRIVERS.
SO HAPPY TO SEE THAT.
RIC AND I HAVE ONLY KNOWN EACH
OTHER FOR 25 YEARS, FULL
DISCLOSURE, WE SHOULDN'T SAY HOW
LONG, BUT A LONG TIME.
>> I WAS, LIKE, SEVEN.
>> Laura: YOU WERE BASICALLY
IN UTERO STILL.
LET'S TALK ABOUT A BUNCH OF
THINGS.
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT MERKEL
WITHDRAWN BUT I HAVE TO PLAY
SOMETHING BECAUSE I HAD NOT
HEARD THIS THIS ON BREAD, TILL
WE WERE GETTING READY FOR THIS S
WE WERE GETTING READY FOR THIS O
WE WERE GETTING READY FOR THIS .
THIS WAS MENENDEZ,
SENATOR MENENDEZ, BEFORE YOUR
CONFIRMATION VOTE.
LET'S WATCH.
>> MR. GRENELL DEROGATORY
COMMENTS ABOUT WOMEN ARE SIMPLY
UNACCEPTABLE FOR ANYONE TO MAKE
IN PUBLIC LET ALONE A DIPLOMAT.
I WOULD GO FURTHER, NOT ONLY DO
THESE TWEETS SHOW BAD JUDGMENT,
THEY SHOW US WHO MR. GRENELL
REALLY IS AND HOW COMFORTABLE HE
IS PUBLICLY CONTRIBUTING HIS OWN
BRAND OF TOXIC POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
WILL HE DO SUCH THINGS IF HE IS
CONFIRMED AND GOES TO GERMANY?
WILL HE INSULT VIA HIS TWITTER
ACCOUNT TO A FEMALE CHANCELLOR
OF GERMANY?
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
I MEAN, RIC, I GOT TO SAY, THIS
WAS -- WITH BOB MENENDEZ IS
PAST, THAT WAS ONE OF THE MOST
HILARIOUS MOMENTS.
THAT IS HOW DESPERATE -- YOU
SEND OUT A SNARKY TWEET FIVE
YEARS AGO, I DON'T EVEN KNOW